da sind wir bei corona bei der pandemie
wie nehmen sie das wahr ich ich ich habe
sie vollen zitiert auch ein einführungs
thema wird mir auch gleich die meinung
von herrn buschmann interessieren ich
meine was doch gerade abläuft mit blick
zum beispiel auch auf die schulen ist
glaubt karl lauterbach hat dieser tage
auch ähnlich formuliert der läuft im
grunde eine stille durchseuchung der
kinder ist ein furchtbares wort ich
finde ganz nebenbei und keiner redet
darüber weil in drei wochen der
bundestagswahl ansteht
ich kann man das so zugespitzt
formulieren mir ja also ob das die
politische motivation ist weiß ich nicht
genau das ist nicht mein spezialgebiet
aber ich stelle fest dass man nicht
drüber redet ja und wir in dieser ganzen
pandemie eigentlich diese offene
diskussion da ist es ja wäre es ja
eigentlich besonders einfach einfacher
als bei so fragen soll ich die steuer
erhöhen oder nicht ist ja der
algorithmus eine pandemie zu steuern im
grunde viel einfacher aber es wird
trotzdem nicht begründet warum man
maßnahmen macht ich habe ja schon
verlangen mal gesagt wir brauchen da
eigentlich eine begründung des kultur
weil weil die die menschen müssen
verstehen warum das so ist warum man was
macht und welche konsequenzen es hat
wenn man wenn man öffnen öffnet das war
nach dem ersten lockdown schon so dann
ist das immer so dass man zugleich eine
höhere durch solche und kriegt das ist
die mechanik hier und ich finde das muss
man diskutieren muss man sagen auf der
einen seite ist ein gewisse freiheiten
auf der anderen seite sind opfer und
nachteile die man hat und im moment ist
die situation für die erwachsenen so
charmant dass sie ja zum großen teil
geimpft sind wir sind ja in der
komfortablen situation 70 prozent der
erwachsenen sind im moment geimpft das
ist eigentlich ganz gut mal was
positives
finde wir sind da sehr viel weiter
gekommen bis hin geht noch aber ich
glaube das ist eine hervorragende
situation wenn wir jetzt bei den
erwachsenen sagen würden wir öffnen die
schleusen dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich
so ähnlich wie in england gar nicht mal
so eine hohe belastung der krankenhäuser
aber wir machen für die erwachsenen
jetzt freiheiten
es gibt sogar diskotheken die wieder
aufmachen und so weiter und so weiter
wir lassen leute aus dem urlaub
zurückkommen um getestet und die
einzigen die es sozusagen richtig
abkriegen sind natürlich die unter 18
weil die zwölf- bis 18-jährigen erst
seit kurzem geimpft die sind noch nicht
immunisiert das ist auch die frage ob
das die eltern dass alle wollen und bei
den noch jüngeren ist sowieso klar dass
der kampf werden und ich glaube das muss
man offen diskutieren das wenn man jetzt
die inzidenz sozusagen ins glas zu
schließen lässt der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja gesagt
die inzidenz hat ausgedient sozusagen
als steuerparadies dann
werden diejenigen die sich infizieren
und das sehen wir in nrw zum beispiel
gerade werden halt die jugendlichen und
kinder seien ja
lauterbach es ist traurig aber wahr bei
den kindern in nrw verlieren wir gerade
komplett die kontrolle und niemand will
im wahlkampf darüber sprechen was
abläuft ist eine stille durchseuchung 27
gerecht und dass das interessante ist ja
wir sind ja wir wissen jetzt im endspiel
dieser pandemie also das virus als
gegner wenn ich mal so sagen darf ist
ist da sind wir jetzt in folgender
situation wir haben durch die impfungen
die passiert sind eigentlich ziemlich
viel puffer bei der frage wann sind die
krankenhäuser voll also die medizinische
belastung die hauptsächlich ältere
menschen betrifft an menschen mit
besonderem risiko die ist eigentlich
ganz gut unter kontrolle im moment der
faktor ist wahrscheinlich eins zu zehn
das heißt wir können uns rein
theoretisch zehnmal soviel incidents
erlauben wie noch in den letzten willen
das haben uns die briten gerade vor gott
sagen sie haben in england sehen das war
das experiment der boris johnson hat ja
damit freedom day quasi so ein
experiment gemacht also das kann man
sehr ambivalenten ich wäre natürlich
total dagegen gewesen aber als
epidemiologe habe ich mir das gerne
angeschaut und das ergebnis ist dass man
sehr hohe instanzen hat aber in england
zumindest und diesen so ähnlich
gestartet aus einer ähnlichen position
wie wir jetzt sind da ist es so dass die
belastung der krankenhäuser und auch die
todesfälle nur ein zehntel sind im
verhältnis zu incidence als noch bei den
letzten wo man keine impfung hatte also
das heißt da haben wir jetzt luft dieser
teil ist in gewisser weise könnte man
sagen verantwortbar müsste man noch ein
paar risikogruppen impfen es ist klar
dass es menschen gibt die
bildungsfernsehen die nicht verstehen
worum es geht bei dem ganzen und die man
vielleicht noch überzeugen könnte und
die trotzdem im risiko sind aber wir
haben eben ein zweites problem und das
sind die schäden die bei jungen menschen
entstehen also unter 18-jährige werden
jetzt nicht schwer krank das muss man
ganz klar sagen hat auch die
impfkommission hört sich noch mal betont
aber die kriegen ja das was ich immer
sekundäre kollateralschäden er ab das
heißt also die schäden die durch die
maßnahmen entstehen und wenn sie jetzt
die inzidenz hoch schießen lassen dann
müssen sie die schulen schließen weil
sie können keinen eltern sagen da ist
zwar jetzt gerade corona palast aber du
musst dein kind trotzdem hin schicken
das wird dann angesteckt das ist auch
juristisch schwierig ist ja und das geht
auch nicht also dieses neue medizinisch
technischen regeln wo wir sagen da sind
wir in dem ich wie wir das dann nennen
dass das musst du einfach machen
allgemeines lebensrisiko ich sag mal zum
beispiel herpes-viren ja die gibt es
auch schon immer da kriegt man auch mal
ein fieber bläschen ganz wenige menschen
sterben auch an schlimmen
hirnhautentzündungen oder sie kennen
alle die streptokokken irgendwelche
bakterien die halsentzündung machen
manche kriegen an rheuma das sind so
sachen wo wir sagen na ja gut das ist
das normale lebensrisiko deshalb kann
man nicht sagen ich schicke mein kind
nicht in die schule aber das ist jetzt
eine völlig neue erreger wo wir nicht
wissen auch wenn es jetzt für die kinder
wirklich gut aussieht was das für
langzeiteffekte hat darum kann man
meines erachtens auf keinen fall sagen
ihr müsst es in kauf nehmen dh es wird
dann schulschließungen geben wenn die
inzidenz hoch geht und wenn ich einer
wesel 30.000 kinder bereits oder schüler
ihren charakter und da gibt es keine
alternative dazu weil weil weil sie das
sie kriegen kein gutachter sagt dass
dieses virus bei unter 18 jährigen
niemals irgendwelche schäden macht da
ist die karte dazu ja das ist die
jetzige situation da kommt glaube ich
einer der kanzlerkandidaten her aus der
ecke ist also das ist einfach wahnsinnig
schwierig das so laufen zu lassen und
das war klar das ist nicht so dass jetzt
man sagt hoch da passiert sowas sondern
das ist ja seit monaten klar dass das
die welle der jungen leute gibt die
karte der vier bis 15 jährigen
ja das kenne ich von hier aus nicht aber
das ist so dass bei den jungen leuten
ist es am schlimmsten also um 55 5 bis
14 jahren und was wir letztlich was wir
letztlich auch haben ist wir haben ja
diese geimpften die fühlen sich sicher
weil sie gesund sind aber und auch nicht
schlimm krank werden dadurch wird ihr
verhalten riskanter gibt es zwei wege
modell in hamburg jetzt wo ich überhaupt
nichts von halte aus verschiedenen
gründen und so musste dann aber kurz
erläutern com zweig ist davon auch
nichts was man die eben an der geimpfte
oder chinesen sozusagen sehr viele
freiheiten hat dann die getestete nicht
mehr das problem ist dass die geimpften
erwachsenen trotzdem zu einem hohen
prozentsatz des virus noch weitergeben
können die werden nicht mehr schwer
krank mal so grundsätzlich die die
merken es oft nicht und wenn sie
erkältungssymptome haben nehmen sie es
nicht mehr ernst aber da gibt es
verschiedene statistiken aber die
verschiedenen studien aber ich sag mal
so als größenordnung
der schutz bezüglich dieser
infektiosität der liegt bei der delta
variante die wir jetzt haben bei dieser
neuen virus variante in der
größenordnung zwischen 50 und 70 heißt
umgekehrt
drei von zehn oder fünf von zehn können
obwohl sie geimpft sind des virus noch
weitergeben wenn sie angesteckt werden
das heißt wir haben nicht nur die
berühmte welle der ungeimpften jetzt im
herbst sondern wir haben auch eine
nicht erkannte unsichtbare welle der
geimpften und dieser cells baumbauer
dieser tank hatten bomba der ist
sozusagen der der die die inzidenz
hochtreibt und das ist nicht so schlimm
für unsere risikogruppen weil diesen
fast 100 prozent sind deutlich über 90
prozent inzwischen geimpft haben wir gut
im griff
inzwischen aber die sind für die
ungeimpften und jungen leute jetzt das
problem weil wenn die ganze gesellschaft
sagt noch gut 300 incidents ist uns doch
wurscht hauptsache wir sind wieder
locker dann haben sie das gleiche in der
schule die schule kriegt das quasi
gespiegelt wieder und dann können sie
den eltern nicht sagen wir müssen
trotzdem hätten das heißt sie müssen die
schule zu machen
ich meine jetzt reden wir wieder über
schulschließungen ja weil wir verhindern
wollen aber gar keinen fall zu gemacht
werden soll der einzige weg das zu
verhindern und und ich sag nur noch
einmal die projektion ich bin richtig
erschrocken als ich die empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission gesehen hat ja
der gerade ihre meinung geändert was die
impfung von 12 bis 17 jahren betrifft da
haben die eine neue modellierung gemacht
und da sagen die sinngemäß dass wir
anfang oktober eine instanz von 500
haben werden 500 also sieben tages
institute und was heißt das übersetzt
das haben wir dann zur ersten des virus
sozusagen in einem herbst orkan
unterwegs ist dass wir die
krankheitslast bei den erwachsenen durch
die impfungen wahrscheinlich irgendwie
abfangen werden ich persönlich glaube
nicht dass wir irgendwie eine eine
situation haben werden wo die
intensivstationen überlastet sind ich
glaube dass das nur aus dem schneider
also das gute nachricht aber das heißt
dass die die sozusagen im sturm stehen
eben die jungen leute sind da sind wir
dann solche instanzen haben bei jungen
leuten dann sagt doch auch da irgendwann
mal die schlägt doch einfach auch die
logik der statistik zu dann haben wir
doch also irgendwann mal auch jüngere
menschen im krankenhaus ja das wird viel
gesagt also da muss man ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein es ist so da wird muss
man wirklich sagen wird auch gibt es
auch fake news die von gutmeinenden
leuten verbreitet werden da wird dann
gesagt ja es gibt
0,01 prozent
sterblichkeit oder schwerste verläufe
und da wird dann einfach eine null zu
wenig in diesen angaben gemacht und das
dass das setzt sich dann sofort also die
wahrscheinlichkeit für in den wirklich
schwersten verlauf oder tödlichen
verlauf bei kindern ist deutlich unter 1
zu 100.000 also wirklich wirklich gering
und ich weiß dass in den auch seriösen
medien kursieren andere zahlen die aber
dann das kleingedruckte nicht gelesen
haben longo witt bei klein also auch
noko wie zum beispiel das sagt jetzt die
ständige impfkommission dass bei den 12
bis 17 jährigen hans genau geprüft auch
unter berücksichtigung aller aktuellen
daten es noch karten noch keinen beleg
dafür gibt dass das überhaupt existiert
als phänomen weil die studien die man
hat wo man dann störungen hat
schlafstörungen und so weiter bei den
kindern die noch länger dauern die da
könnten die störungen immer genauso gut
auf die auf die mars corinna maßnahmen
also loks und zurückzuführen sein und
ich persönlich glaube dass es bei
jugendlichen und kindern auch
wahrscheinlich in einzelfällen longo
wird geben wird aber das ist nicht der
hauptgrund warum wir uns jetzt hier
sozusagen aufpassen müssen sondern weil
wir müssen deshalb aufpassen wie gesagt
weil diese sekundären schäden also die
schulschließungen und das geht ja nicht
nur auf die kinder das geht ja auch auf
die eltern dann die dann wieder zu hause
bleiben musste das ist etwas das meine
ich müssen wir im herbst verhindern gibt
es eigentlich um das mal ganz große
interessehalber zu fragen die es
mittlerweile eine erklärung dafür warum
diese krankheit bei kindern so so
harmlos weiß nicht verläuft ja das ist
relativ klar es ist so wir haben ja zwei
stufen der immunantwort die erste stufe
ist dass das angeborenes immunsystem
nennen dieses angeborene immunsystem das
funktioniert so dass es quasi sofort
losschlägt egal welcher erreger das ist
und so eine grund aktivität macht und
schnell ist und das was durch die
impfung gemacht wird und durch durch
durch durchgemachte krankheiten passiert
das ist das lernen die immunsystem und
diese dieses lernen die immunsystem wo
die antikörper kommen und so weiter das
braucht ein bisschen länger bei kindern
die haben ja noch nicht so viele
krankheitserreger erlebt im leben
deshalb haben sie noch nicht so viele
antikörper die spezifisch gegen
bestimmte erreger gehen und die haben
stattdessen eine sage ich mal ständige
grund aktivierung dieser angeborenen
immunantwort auf den schleimhäuten der
atemwege ins ist die hoffen schon dass
wir diese zusagen gemacht da oben und
dadurch ist ein erreger der kommt quasi
viel schneller eliminiert als kommt erst
gar nicht mehr die lunge wo es gerne im
weiteren verlauf des lebens schaltet man
sozusagen um von diesen uralt system das
firma und pflanzen auf das modernere
system der adaptiven immunität wie wir
nennen sozusagen die haie antwort und
die funktioniert dann über antikörper
und bestimmte zellen die sich den
erreger gemerkt haben übrigens ist das
auch der grund warum die impfung es war
die krankheit verhindert weil die
nämlich das kriegt man in den arm und
nicht auf die schleimhäute die im system
verhindert die durch antikörper dass man
schwer krank wird wenn das virus im
körper kommt wird sozusagen gestoppten
vor sind ihre organe befällt aber die
impfung verhindert nicht so gut die
infektion der schleimhäute weil da sind
keine antikörper diese angeborene
immunantwort wird auf den schleimhäuten
dadurch nicht trainiert und deshalb sind
geimpfte
ebenso wie malta anstecken wenn es
weiter geben obwohl sie nicht schwer
krank werden weil das virus kommt
sozusagen nur verstehe und das ist der
grund warum nehme ich an sie sagen von
2g halte ich eigentlich nicht weil auch
geimpfte könnte das ding weiter gift ja
wenn jedoch erst durch rechne nicht so
ganz einfach gesagt 1 1 nur getesteter
der hat wahrscheinlich eine 20 prozent
chance sag ich mal pessimistisch dass
der test falsche negativ war weil diese
tests nicht perfekt sind die anti gen
test eingeimpft hat ungefähr der
gleichen ordnung größenordnung die
chance dass er trotz impfungen sich
infiziert hat das ist ja weil die
impfung eben nicht perfekt ist mit delta
das heißt sie haben sie also
vergleichbare risiken bezüglich der
ansteckungsfähigkeit aber höchst
unterschiedliches verhalten weil der
geimpfte ja denkt dass haben den usa
1000 beispiele dafür da gibt es auch
studien der rabattierung der geimpfte
denkt er kann jetzt nicht mehr passieren
ich werde zumindest nicht daran sterben
also gehe ich ins risiko ich habe keine
maske hält sich gelassen klagte ich gehe
in hamburg in die 2g discos und so
weiter und er lässt sich nicht mehr
testen und dadurch kriegen sie im grunde
genommen eine unsichtbare welle und drei
kleine deutschland bedeutet dass man
gleiches gleich behalten buschmann warum
ist die fdp so gegen 2
das hat er regulär gerade beschauen aus
dem grund ja ja ja weil wir
vergleichbare dinge nicht
unterschiedlich behandeln dürfe wenn wir
menschen in ihrer freiheit einschränken
wofür das gründe geben kann
beispielsweise weil von ihnen eine
gefahr ausgeht und das ist bei diesen
gruppen in vergleichbarer weise der fall
dann müssen sie auch ähnlich behandelt
also wenn man entweder sagt man dieser
test hat eine aussagekraft und ich kann
was mit dem ergebnis anfangen das hat
der kunde ausgeführt dann kann es auch
nicht sein wenn ich da zu dem ergebnis
kommen dass dieser mensch dann wenn er
getestet ist nicht gefährlicher ist als
die anderen gruppen dann kann ich ihnen
auch in seiner freiheit nicht stärker
beeinträchtigen als die anderen da steht
der gleichheitsgrundsatz des
grundgesetzes gegen und auch das
grundprinzip dass die bürger erstmal
frei sind und wenn ich keine gute
begründung habe in ihrer freiheit
einzugreifen dann darf ich das als staat
nicht das ist das rechtsstaats
vielleicht darf ich zu den der
juristischen seite noch eins ergänzen
auch wenn es irritiert holtorf ist
sozusagen ich hab mal geguckt es gibt ja
das urteil des verwaltungsgerichts in
berlin war es gesagt hat ihr dürft jetzt
dieses verbot für die tanz tanzlokals
lustbarkeiten heißt ist hans lustbarkeit
nicht mehr aufrechterhalten
die haben sich berufen auf die webseite
des robert koch instituts das ist eine
einstweilige anordnung gewesen die
gucken da noch mal schnell im internet
nach und auf der website des robert koch
instituts steht und das gericht zitierte
darauf dass die geimpften und die
genesenen keinen wesentlichen beitrag
zur epidemie mehr leisten würden eine
eine komplette falschaussage und auf die
stützt sich jetzt das gericht das ist
wahrscheinlich veraltet so eine kleine
motivation sich impfen zu lassen das
aber wir wissen natürlich aus den daten
des letzten monats ungefähr
hauptsächlich aus den usa aus england
aus israel müssen wir eben dass diese
impfungen unvollständig sind jetzt lasse
ich einmal putz die richterinnen und
richter in schutz nehme ich sie
natürlich nur ist aus himmel gemacht und
können ja gar nicht anders als sich
wanda informationen der offizielle teil
davon kommen wenn ich die chance die
frage ist warum steht so war es im
internet obwohl wahrscheinlich jeder
fachmann vom robert-koch-institut den
sie fragen würden die ganzen studien
kennt ja das müssen wir den
gesundheitsminister der die
aufsichtsführende behörde des
robert-koch-instituts ist sehen sie auch
sofort uns weil kann man natürlich auch
andersrum argumentieren ich finde für
die 2g regel ich finde dass diejenigen
die den großen beitrag auch im bemühen
um eine herdenimmunität
leisten früher zu den freiheiten
zurückkommen müssten ich akzeptiere dass
menschen sagen sie möchten sich nicht
impfen lassen unabhängig von denen die
es aus gesundheitlichen gründen nicht
können und ich möchte umgekehrt dass die
sogenannten impfverweigerer akzeptieren
dass ich freiheiten zurück haben möchte
und ich finde dass wir da schon ein
bischen gewichten können es ist
natürlich auch um druck zu machen um
noch mal ein anreiz zu schaffen dass wir
schneller zu einer höheren quote kommen
können und
ich finde das kann man ruhig klar
benennen und was macht man aber nicht zu
diesem jahr der jugend will ich aber
trotzdem was sagen also sie haben
wahrscheinlich recht dass man so ein
paar unentschlossene oder faule die
keinen bock mehr haben sich immer testen
zu lassen damit noch kriegt aber folgen
das ist wichtig es heißt ja gg also
geimpft oder gelesen wenn ich das
richtig verfolgt habe ist es öffentlich
dass sie schon mal corona hatte hatten
und es ist so wenn sie krone hatten sind
sie nach sechs monaten nicht mehr
gelesen obwohl unsere ganzen
wissenschaftlichen daten schon lange
zeigen dass der immunschutz durch die
natürliche infektion das ist traurig das
zu sagen aber sogar besser ist als der
zur durch die impfung das ist nichts
keine aufforderung frauen-abfahrt das
ist ja gut also dass also die natürliche
infektion und das schiff gesichert ja
das ist da gibt es sehr viele daten dazu
und das ist das ist in letzter zeit klar
geworden und es ist so dass auf jeden
fall dieser schutz länger anhält als
sechs monate und wenn sie aber sechs
monate überschreiten dann sind sie wenn
sie genesen sind plötzlich im
verweigerer und das finde ich ein
bisschen unfair weil das opfer sie haben
jetzt von opfern oder von dienst an der
gemeinschaft gesprochen
also wenn sie eine corona infektion
durchgemacht haben dann haben sie ja
auch gelitten normalerweise oder
zumindest viele und dann sind sie zum
dank sozusagen immun geworden und gelten
aber als im verweigerer in ihrem system
und werden bestraft wie jemand der sagt
ich lasse mich nicht impfen also ich
finde
das 2g ist in sich schon ein bisschen
asymmetrisch weil eben nur der wirklich
geimpfte und manche müssen sich sogar
zweimal impfen lassen obwohl sie pro
karten wenn sie in die usa fliegen
wollen oder ähnliches also ich glaube
dass das system pädagogisch gesehen
nicht ganz gerecht ist ich finde ich
finde es auch einfach auch da wieder die
überforderung beginnt dann am ende schon
bei der sprache bei der klaren sprache
wie nennen sie das herr busch und was da
gerade passiert mit hier immer mit
abscheu und empörung zurückgewiesen wenn
man dann sagt das ist im grunde eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür die da
kommen wir nennen sie das natürlich ist
also keine impfpflicht im klassischen
juristischen hatte aber dürfen nicht in
eine gute gesellschaft kommen und wenn
frau und sagt ja das pädagogisch das
reicht mir schon als begründung dafür
dass ich in die grundrechte von menschen
die sich aus welchen gründen auch immer
nicht impfen lassen wollen also um das
klarzustellen ich würde jedem empfehlen
das zu tun ja ich wäre auch dafür dass
die leute haben aber wenn wir uns da
reden die sagen wenn leute es nicht
machen sich dann aber testen lassen und
dann aus der wissenschaftlichen
perspektive wir haben hier einen der
bekanntesten experten in deutschland der
sagt dann aber aus der risiko
perspektive vergleichbar gefährlich sind
dann kann ich aus der perspektive des
gefahrenabwehr rechts die dinge nicht
unterschiedlich behandeln das keinem
gefallen oder nicht aber wir sind doch
keine gute gesellschaft wo der staat
entscheidet dessen grundrechte die finde
ich jetzt wichtig und die grundrechte
des anderen obwohl sie erst mal auf die
menschen gleich verteilt sind alle
menschen sind frei die sind mir jetzt
nicht so wichtig sondern aber auch
objektive maßstäbe im gefahren abrecht
abwehrrecht brauchen wir objektive
maßstäbe nie muss uns die wissenschaft
liefern und wenn die wissenschaft sagt
dass diese drei fallgruppen was der
gefahren perspektive vergleichbar sind
dann muss ich sie auch vergleichbar
behandeln alles andere ist nicht in
ordnung ein gerechter als wenn man in
die vergangenheit von solchen schaut
in allen großen
pandemien ob das jetzt die pest waren
oder die pocken waren oder die cholera
zuletzt da ist es natürlich so dass man
sieht dass die gesellschaften gestresst
waren so wie wir auch jetzt alle
gestresst sind jetzt schon fast im
straßenverkehr und es ist so was dann
passiert ist oft der reflex dass man
irgendwie einen schuldigen sucht früher
waren es die brunnenvergifter auch bei
der cholera ist es ganz interessant ist
england die ärzte jedoch da hat man
tatsächlich wurden ärzte vom mob getötet
weil man es gerüchte gab dass die ärzte
die cholera abbaus gesetzt haben um mehr
tote für die sektion zu haben also
völlig absurde theorien damals auch ohne
internet sehr erfolgreich verbreitet und
heute sind wir eine situation wo
natürlich die gefahr groß ist finde ich
jetzt dass dann die gruppe der nicht
impfen aus welchen gründen auch immer
also ich werbe auch 100 für die im gang
ist nicht das thema absolut dafür dass
ich erwachsen impfen lassen
selbstverständlich aber es ist so dass
man höllisch aufpassen muss dass wir das
wichtigste ist doch einmal der
zusammenhalt in sondersituationen und
wenn wir jetzt so eine situation hat das
sind die brunnenvergifter wegen denen
wegen denen können wir jetzt unsere
freiheit nicht dann ist es ja auch
falsch weil das hängt zusammen mit
diesem versprechen was heißt wenn sich
genug leute impfen dann haben wir hatten
immunität dann ist die sache erledigt
das war ja von anfang an eine
falschaussage also jeder fachmann wusste
dieses virus wird sich verändern das
wird keine herdenimmunität geben
trotzdem ist diese wurst immer vor der
nase gewesen und wenn man jetzt sagt
nach diesen jetzt schuld dass die
immunität nicht aufhört und die pandemie
nicht in rente ist nicht eintritt und
die panini zu ende ich halte es für also
der zweite schwierig das ist das einzige
aspekt daran ist dass wir sozusagen dass
der eindruck entstehen kann dass wir
natürlich kinder jetzt benutzen
sozusagen als als ersatz für unwillige
erwachsene ja das ist so weil ich sagen
alle epidemiologen übrigens noch mal die
ständige impfkommission hat sich riesig
viel arbeit gemacht die haben ja klipp
und klar gesagt ihre empfehlung zur
impfung der 12 bis 17 jährigen basiert
nicht darauf dass das irgendeinen
einfluss auf das pandemie geschehen
hätte sollen sie sagen klipp und klar
die einzige möglichkeit diese
altersgruppe effektiv zu schützen ist
die impfung der älteren weil die älteren
schützen stecken die kinder an und aus
den genannten gründen diese nicht so
ansteckend wie die eltern also die haben
klipp und klar gesagt hier geht es nicht
um einen beitrag zur pandemie bekämpfung
für ältere sondern nur darum das halt
die kinder selber halten ist dann nicht
mehr kriegen können und und die ständige
impfkommission hat halt sehr gehofft
dass durch diese empfehlung quasi der
druck auf die kinder nach lässt den
sekundären schäden sozialen
psychologischen schäden bisschen unter
kontrolle gekommen also was spürbar ist
finde ich an vielen ecken ist so eine
überforderung und das ist auch glaube
ich diese gereiztheit die diese
polarisierung die wahlen vielen stellen
spüren